هذا موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا
بكم نظمت قوه احزاب المعارضه ومنظمات
مدنيه مظاهرات وتحركات احتجاجيه رفضا
للاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي اتخذها الرئيس
التونسي ومساره السياسيه الحالي تزاملت
هذه الاحتجاجات مع ذكر الثوره التونسيه
وقال رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه
والاجتماعيه الراهنه واكد شاب انه لم يعد
في وسعي الرئيس السيد ان يقدم شيئا بعدما
فشله في اداره الشؤون اليوميه للمواطنين
حسب تعبير
من جانبه دع الامين العام للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل نور الدين الطبوبي الى
الاستعداد لما سماها معركه وطنيه من اجل
انقاذ تونس معلنا تنفيذ تحركات نقابيه
قطاعيه في قادم الايام
وكان الرئيس التونسي قد قال ان بلاده في
حاله حرب مع الفساد ومع من وصفهم بالخونه
والعملاء
اعلنت سلطات الاوكرانيه انها هجمات روسيه
جديده استهدفت البنيه التحتيه في انحاء
البلاد تزامنا مع احتلال المعارك البريه
شرقيا اقل رئيس الاوكراني انه تم اسقاطه
اكثر من 20 صاروخا من بين اكثر من 30
صاروخ ثم اطلاقها على اوكرانيا امس
مكتب رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريشي سوناك
كان حكومته تسلم كيف 14 دبابه من طرازه
تشالنجر 2 واسلحه ثقيله اخرى الى اوكرانيا
خلال الاسابيع المقبله واوضح مكتب سوناك
من المملكه المتحده ستشرع في تدريب قوات
اوكرانيه على استخدام هذه الدبابات
والمدفعيه في الايام القادمه
قال الناطق باسم الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم
ما يقال ان تركيا ترغب في التشجيع على
الاعلان عن وقف محدود لاطلاق النار بين كل
من روسيا واوكرانيا كخطوه يا احترازيه في
حال عدم النجاح في التواصل الى اتفاقيه
سلام شامله بين الجانبين
اعلن القضاء الايرانيه
مساعد وزير الدفاع السابق بتهمه التجسس
لصالح الاستخبارات البريطانيه وقد استدعت
الخارجيه الايرانيه لديها احتجاجا على ما
وصفتها بالافعال المهدده للامن القومي
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]